to talk about the Democrats phony moral
outrage over sexual abuse were joined by
one of Bill Clinton's accusers Juanita
Broderick and christina hoff sommers an
American Enterprise Institute scholar
who studies politics and gender and
feminism in her classic book the war
against boys kind of went into a lot of
what boys face in society today it's
great to see both of you
Juanita and christina hoff sommers
christina i'ma start with you unpack
what Michelle was talking about there
the former first lady about it's a
dangerous world for women and we kind of
protect our men what was she getting out
there well I and they're also saying
that men grow up to be entitled we're
raising our little boys to be entitled
by self righteous it's so much the
opposite is the case in schools boys
face a rather hostile environment
they're far less likely to get good
grades to go to college and we need to
address those problems and I don't see
entitled little boys I see many many
neglected boys I'm thinking maybe she
was just speaking off-the-cuff and
wasn't think because it just she evinced
such sort of hostility towards little
boys and the men they become and I think
it's a problem that people will take the
worst-case male and then project that
into the entire male population
including little boys and this is
something that's done by sort of
hard-line feminists and we're raising
boys to be to be strong but what does
that mean and we should raise them to be
gentlemen that of course but the thing
that was kind of left out of that
conversation was really fathers and an
intact family which is so important for
for children I mean I'm a single mother
believe I know it's not ideal it can be
finite it's admirable for women to do
it's really tough and it's admirable but
without fathers it's a lot harder
well sociologists experts from the right
and the left have come together it's the
one thing they agree on is the
importance of fathers in the lives of is
particularly sons broken families take a
higher toll on a young male development
absolutely and Juanita I want to go to
you on this issue because
when you listen to Michelle Obama and
she talked about you know protecting men
who clearly talking about men who are
not behaving you know of course it came
to mind Hillary Clinton the ultimate
enabler of a man's abusive behavior
remember the bimbo eruptions what you
allege she said to you all those years
after your allegations that Bill Clinton
sexually assaulted you back in 1978 and
yet Michelle Obama is talking about how
bad it is to protect abusive men oh I
know it's it's absolutely ridiculous and
all I can say is if Michelle Obama truly
thinks and believes in the statements
that she made thank goodness she didn't
raise boys you know and I have no idea
what part maybe Bill Clinton's mother
played in his influencing his life but I
do know that he hid behind the skirt
tale of Hillary Clinton she went after
us with a vengeance I mean and declared
us the bimbo eruption this woman has no
conscience whatsoever and wanita from
all these years later does does any of
this surprise you you know the
Weinsteins and the Clintons come out
five days later after Harvey Weinstein
allegations one after the other after
the other surface and no I was like
counting how many days is it gonna take
for both the Obamas and the Clintons to
come out with a statement pretty much
all these people were coming out except
the you know close friends I know it's
it's absolutely ridiculous Laura that
they waited that length of time to come
out they were close to Weinstein they I
bet you that they knew exactly what was
going on in his territory it's hard to
believe Christina by the way that Bill
Clinton who's as sophisticated as he is
and Hillary Clinton who's Mosley as
smart as she is they didn't know what
even I knew or I'd heard about Harvey
Weinstein going all the way back to 1997
but they were saying oh would never
heard of anything like this yeah the
well there were a lot of enablers and
you know there's hypocrisy what do you
think about the whole Hollywood no I
mean I'm gonna get into that later but
they tie one incident after another it's
just all one second one Oh a Hollywood
spectrum they're always wagging their
fingers moralizing about recycling and
global warming when the environments the
moralizing and while allowing this to go
on and really not taking people knew
about it there were no efforts to
control it in some way and hopefully
it'll change my only worry is that we're
going to go from indifference to sexual
predation into a kind of vigilantism era
because I saw a few days ago it's there
was an article in The Washington Post by
someone that was indignant about George
Bush Senior he had touched in his
wheelchair at 93 he just touched someone
and he spoke about a toxic environment
and so all I care again all men are
implicated in the crimes of yes worried
I'm worried now you're right and Anita
and Christina that you can't even like
tell a woman well you look you look
great today or I love your outfit like
men are gonna be afraid they're gonna be
afraid to say anything because there's
now we've gone to a sterile work
environment REME opposite it's now and
that will road and that makes it
everything on fun so there has to be a
middle ground of just treating each
other well and and treating each other
yes kindness kindness fit yes
courteousness
and we need to thank you for joining us
Christina thank you so much for joining
us